the United States of America you to
Hawaii and Alaska to scale for once ever
since these states United to create
America the federal government of
America they and she fought mightily
over the land which plains our forests
or mountains or swamps to end up in each
hand on the map it looks like States
hold all the cards but they don't just
under one-third of land in the United
States is federal but that's an average
looking at the percent of federal land
in the state's the Wester we go the
federal or the land and the less of the
state that's in each state there's
eastern states with under 1% federal
land and five western states that
control less than half of the land in
their borders how what first thing first
how did this happen
America wasn't always the mighty United
like us all she started small when
states were young new and few giving
away but little for her to play but then
America grew Louisiana purchasing
Mexican sessioning and manifest destiny
her way across the continent but in this
age of empires it won't do any good to
say she owns the land unless she gets
her citizens out there to occupy the
vast totally unoccupied continent so
America turns from hoarder to minimalist
disposing of as much of the land to new
States and new settlers as she can
sometimes giving it away in literal
races where plots of land were drawn
homesteaders waited at a starting line
and bang first family to a plot owns
that plot says who says America she's
booting up a private property ladder
from virgin land using contracts and
guns 10% of all the land in the US was
given away for free just to get people
out west
see also railroad companies which got
the land either side of any track they
could build for the length of a
continent if you could live on or
improve the land in the 1800's America
would probably give it to you but by the
1900's most of the states are mostly in
place and the age of empires and wagons
westward is over but America still had a
ton of land she didn't or couldn't give
away and now that the states are settled
well what she has is all she will ever
have she turns away from her gifting
minimalism
and becomes a curator of her collection
of land this change was rather a shock
to States expecting the land in their
borders would be land in their borders
that federal land would continue to be
turned over as it had for a century but
now thus this map and a lot of angry
western states now up against a fully
operational federal government altering
the deal some states like poor Utah and
Nevada found themselves with hardly any
state in their state or hey hey what
about the reservations are you going to
talk about them
are they federal land some of us have a
lot of reservations in our state ah the
reservations yes what a great story for
another time look we can't do the
reservations right now we just can't
okay history aside America has all this
land now but like what is it for what is
it for a lot almost all of the following
will have an in general before it
because there are almost 2,000 separate
bureaucracies administering land that
were at a single country would be in the
top ten list of biggest countries but in
general most of the federal land falls
under the control of the President to
whom a dozen secretaries report of which
we care about three that run five
departments first the Department of
Defense she runs military bases and
nuclear silos and all the toys of war
America has to keep them somewhere and
ifs Aurora sighed taught her anything
it's don't trust the states with weapons
so keep them close on federal lands she
does while America's military is big the
Department of Defense holds the least
land of the top five next is the
National Park Service but Grand Canyon
and Yellowstone and Blue Ridge Mountains
if there's an epic Vista you visited or
heard of in America it's probably one of
hers National Parks is the celebrity of
the group and can really stand out next
biggest is the Fish and Wildlife Service
much less known except if you're in
Alaska where PD five percent of her land
is fish and wildlife is in the business
of animal conservation keeping land for
America's species under her Aegis not to
be developed
then there's the Forest Service often
confused with national parks but not
remotely the same there's many a
breathtaking National Forest you can
hike through but they're not parks
they're more America's resource
miles least for logging plus grassland
tiles for grazing Forest Service's job
is to balance extraction with
maintenance how well she does this is an
endless source of argument between
America and the states and the companies
that want to use those resource tiles
it's a job that guarantees someone is
always going to be angry only you can
prevent forest fires
that's the Forest Service because she
deals with these kinds of fires as well
as these kinds of fires and it's a job
she splits with the last and the biggest
the Bureau of Land Management she does
it all from resolving cow disputes to
leasing land for mining to building
parks to preserving the coastal waters
of California which surprised California
our federal land BLM does a lot and is
the biggest which can make it very
confusing about which agency does what
but think of it this way there are three
goals conservation recreation extraction
BLM does all three FS does conservation
and extraction F and W does conservation
NPS conservation recreation again in
general these four plus war control 97%
of federal land the last three percent
is miscellaneous used by departments
like the Postal Service or NASA or the
Department of Energy or others okay this
is lovely but like what does it mean to
say that land is federal is it part of
the state or not well this brings up the
delicate and sensitive balance of power
between the States and America and
there's an enormous amount of words
words words around the sovereignty of
governments but ultimately federal land
belongs to America and she can do with
it what she wants and the states have to
just suck it most starkly in Nevada
where federal land was used for nuclear
bomb testing yeah that's a that's a
pretty big hole you punched in nevada
america oh not just the once oh oh oh
when push comes to shove america can
shove that's the most extreme example
but federal lands will often have their
own separate federal law enforcement
officers like the investigative services
branch a kind of FBI for national parks
though state borders do matter here for
lesser crimes federal officers will
often dump suspects into the state
courts to deal with private citizens
can't
property on federal land there are
Americans who will tell you they live in
a National Park Cape Cod and Fire Island
national parks are examples of this but
if you zoom into official Maps you'll
often find hilarious borders that swoop
around and in between developed and
undeveloped areas there's also military
bases which will have soldiers living in
them but they can't own anything and
because it's federal land the Department
of Defense that builds the housing can
ignore all estate's laws about housing
or health codes so a state can't control
in a meaningful way federal land in her
borders hundreds of acres of federal
grassland might suddenly be filled with
grazing cattle or pow be declared a
national monument and preserved forever
or plumbed for oil and mined for
minerals with the state just standing on
the sidelines watching thus states can't
build their own towns or parks or
factories in federal land to you know
collect any taxes from the land which
once America made her intention to keep
federal land forever made the states
with a lot of it start to grumble
grumble grumble grumble fine I'll give
you payment in lieu of taxes are you
happy now is this a joke is this for
real
grumble grumble grumble grumble all of
this means today there's a big political
divide between the states that have a
lot of federal land and the states that
don't with eastern states thinking of
federal land as belonging to the nation
as a whole which is easy to do when you
don't have a lot of it within your
borders and federal land to you means
visiting Glacier National Park on
vacation meanwhile Western states are
getting nuclear bombs detonated in their
backyards and compensation they don't
think is fair for land that affects them
that they can't control there's a
million more complications this
simplification can't possibly cover but
the best way to think about federal land
is that while it may be in a state it is
not of the state
[Music]
you